[Música]
y
cada día nos enfrentamos a un mar de
decisiones algunas son pequeñas y sin
importancia pero otras tienen un mayor
impacto en nuestras vidas por ejemplo a
qué político votar debo probar lo último
en dietas o enviar un correo electrónico
me hará millonario
nos bombardean con tantas decisiones que
es imposible decantarse por la decisión
correcta cada vez pero hay muchas
maneras de mejorar nuestras
posibilidades y una técnica
particularmente eficaz es el pensamiento
crítico esta es una manera de acercarse
a una pregunta que nos permite
deconstruir cuidadosamente una situación
revelar sus problemas ocultos como los
prejuicios y la manipulación y tomar la
mejor decisión si la parte crítica suena
algo negativo es porque en cierto modo
lo es en lugar de elegir una respuesta
porque parece y suena bien una persona
que usa pensamiento crítico sopesa las
alternativas disponibles y las examina
con escepticismo con la ayuda de las
herramientas que están a su disposición
dejará de lado todo salvo la información
más útil y fiable
hay muchas maneras diferentes de
acercarse al pensamiento crítico y aquí
se describe un proceso en cinco pasos
que puede ayudarte a solucionar
cualquier problema el primer paso
formula tu pregunta tengo otras palabras
debes saber qué buscas esto no siempre
es tan sencillo como parece
por ejemplo si te decides a probar lo
último en dietas otros factores pueden
complicar tu motivación para hacerlo
como la afirmación de que se pueden ver
resultados en solo dos semanas
pero si adoptas tu enfoque con una
visión clara de lo que tratas de lograr
con la dieta
sea bajar de peso una alimentación más
sana o una recarga de energía esto te
ayudará a navegar a través de esta
información de manera crítica encontrar
lo que estás buscando y decidir si este
nuevo capricho realmente se adapta a tus
necesidades
segundo paso recopila tu información hay
muchos datos así que tener una idea
clara te ayudará a determinar lo
relevante si estás tratando de decidirte
sobre una dieta para mejorar tu
alimentación a lo mejor pides el consejo
de los expertos o buscas los testimonios
de otras personas la recopilación de
información te ayuda a superar
diferentes opciones lo que te lleva más
cerca de la decisión que te ayuda a
alcanzar tu meta tercer paso pone en
práctica la información algo que se
logra haciendo preguntas críticas frente
a una decisión pregúntate qué conceptos
funcionan en este caso qué suposiciones
existen es mi interpretación de la
información válida lógicamente por
ejemplo en un correo electrónico que te
promete millones debes tener en cuenta
qué factores están en juego en esta
situación
supongo que el remitente está diciendo
basándome en la evidencia es lógico
suponer que voy a ganar dinero
cuarto paso tener en cuenta las
consecuencias imagina que hay elecciones
y te has decidido por un candidato
político con base en su promesa de bajar
los precios de la gasolina a primera
vista
esto suena muy bien pero qué pasa con
los efectos sobre el medio ambiente a
largo plazo si el consumo de gasolina no
baja debido a su precio esto también
podría causar un enorme aumento en la
contaminación del aire una consecuencia
no deseada que es importante considerar
quinto paso considera otros puntos de
vista pregúntate por qué tantas personas
se sienten atraídas por la política del
candidato político de la oposición
incluso si no estás de acuerdo con nada
de lo que dice ese candidato considerar
todos los puntos de vista podría aclarar
porque algunas políticas que no parecen
válidas sí lo son para los demás esto te
permitirá considerar otras alternativas
evaluar tus propias decisiones y en
última instancia te ayudará a tomar más
decisiones bien fundamentadas este
proceso en cinco pasos es sólo una
herramienta y ciertamente no erradicará
las decisiones difíciles de nuestras
vidas pero puede ayudarnos a aumentar el
número de decisiones positivas que
tomamos el pensamiento crítico nos puede
brindar las herramientas necesarias para
enfrentarnos a un mar de decisiones y
encontrar lo que estamos buscando y si
muchos pensamos críticamente eso hará
del mundo un lugar más razonable
sabe qué cosa racional podría hacer
ahora suscribirse a este canal siga
satisfaciendo su curiosidad y ponga a
prueba su pensamiento crítico con
animaciones sobre todo tipo de temas
incluido cómo tomar la siesta perfecta y
la historia de los gatos
ah
[Música]